("Siri" by LRYBRDBTZ)
- [Gary] Hey man,
how are you?
Understand.
Alright, awesome.
All good stuff, mom. Busy.
Yeah, better than
the alternative.
Yeah, Xan Man.
Jimmy Cricket, Jiminy Cricket.
("Siri" by LRYBRDBTZ)
- [Tyler] Coffee?
- Please.
Ready?
We just really need to
think about what we're doing
from our pitch deck
and our website.
I'd like to make
those decisions now
so that we're in
a good place for,
you know, December 1.
Jeff, how are you my friend?
Ohio life, right? (laughs)
Listen, it's really
nice to connect.
I've been keeping
tabs through Peter.
It sounds like things are
going well and I'm happy.
I know you're super busy so
I wanted to grab two minutes
to A, say hello and
B, we've been doing
a social digital audit
product here at Vayner
that's been going
extremely well,
and I wanted to make
some curve balls to it,
so I did a few things on
spec to teach my ninja team
that I put on it
how I want it done.
One of brands I asked them
to do it on was (censored)
just 'cause I knew you
were there, and by the way,
I'm super aware are
of (censored) and all this,
but I'm playing long game
with our relationship,
so I wanted to send that over
to you with the context of
I wanted you to see it because
I think it's valuable insight
and I want you to use it with
whoever you're working with.
I'm not worried about getting
(censored) business this time,
I'm worried about
staying in your circle,
'cause I believe in you,
and so I was gonna do
the spec work anyway,
so I figured I might as well
do it on three or
four brands that were
relationships outside
my current roster.
We have something pretty
cool, I think you'll enjoy it.
I'm gonna send it to you.
Feel free, if you
want any clarification,
you can call me directly.
I mean, we've been having
some crazy results with
(censored) with (censored)
like real stuff.
If you find yourself
in New York, stop by.
I'm thrilled to show
you under the hood.
You know, we are, I mean
it's just black and white.
If you wanna sell
(censored)
at Albertsons
you can prove it, it's just
everybody's more reliant
on Nielsen and
modelling mixes internally
than actual depletion reports.
On (censored) our
MMM says we're losing,
and our sales are
through the roof
because we're running
Facebook as TV commercials
and the MMM
doesn't recognize it.
The end.
I'm willing to give a lot,
because I have a much bigger
plan than your current
role, so we'll talk soon.
I'll send that over.
Take care man, bye bye.
("Siri" by LRYBRDBTZ)
We got to talk to
Vimeo's comps and
see if they care
about anything.
Thank you.
Morning.
Hello.
- [Woman] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Pleased to see
you, nice to meet you.
- Pleasure, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
(mumbles)
Should I speak Spanish?
- If you want to.
- I can't, I can't.
(laughter)
- Alrighty (in Spanish).
- So I think the biggest
thing that every immigrant
watching this, and every
person, but obviously
being an immigrant I have those
feelings for that audience,
is you've already won.
See, that's what
people don't understand.
- [Carlos] There you go.
- You've already won.
Let me explain.
Picking the right business,
having the right talent
to see where the world's going.
There's intuition,
there's nothing I can say
to make you do that,
there's talent,
there's timing, there's luck.
That's real.
I'm not worried about that,
you know why?
I'm not in control of that,
nor are they.
I'll tell you what they
are in control of.
The reason they've already won.
They're just willing
to work much harder
than the people that live in
the place that they were born.
When you are born in America,
when you are born in the UK,
when you are born in
Canada, when you're born
in these places that have
stability of democracy
for a long period of time,
you're softer.
- [Carlos] Correct.
- I don't know,
I'm willing to go work
picking up garbage right now.
- [Carlos] Yeah.
- Right now.
- It just doesn't
seem so crazy to me.
- [Carlos] Not at all.
- I just did it, I've done it.
I don't know what else to say.
- [Carlos] Mhmmm.
- When you realize you go
to a land of opportunity,
when you leave Venezuela,
I don't give a shit
if you were an engineer,
a doctor, you know,
the wealthiest car dealership,
when you've lived through
one, two, three, five,
seven, nine years of
dictatorship, communism,
socialism at scale, and
you get to leave somehow,
and go to a place of capitalism,
you're willing to wash dishes.
You're willing to drive a taxi.
You just are, 'cause you're so
grateful for the opportunity.
- [Carlos] That is correct.
- That's it.
- [Carlos] Totally.
- And so, the things
I normally preach,
patience, immigrants have that.
Immigrants come and they're
patient as fuck, you know?
They live in shitty apartments,
they don't buy nice things,
they eat minimally
and they save,
and they save, and they
save, and so, you know,
I think, especially the
current political climate
in America where there
is a big group of people
pushing against immigrants,
I understand how an immigrant
can get down, can get worried,
can get concerned,
can get bummed out.
I give them the
recommendation that I live with,
which is put your head
down, work, and everything
has a funny way
of working itself out.
And remember that
you've got it better.
If you're complaining
about immigrants,
you've already
lost to immigrants.
Alright, my friend.
- [Carlos] Thank you so much.
- So nice to meet--
("Wholie" by LRYBRDBTZ)
Yeah, because there
might not be one.
- Hey.
- [Gary] How are you?
- So good, how are you?
- [Gary] You travel
with tripods?
- I'm doing a favor for Paulina
who's on the Spotify account
- I love it. (laughs)
- [Woman 2] She needed
a stabilizer, (laughs)
I was like,
I'll bring it over. (laughs)
- [Gary] That's awesome,
how are you?
- Awesome!
- [Gary] Good.
It's a real pleasure.
- Yeah, so good to
finally meet you.
- [Gary] How long have
you been at Vayner?
- Nine months.
- Sorry it took so long.
Do you feel like
you have the outlet
to come and speak to Claude,
me, or Erin, or Dylan,
or Jason,
or does that feel like,
ooh, that's like a big, to go
up there, to ask for that
may be inappropriate or
too big of an ask.
- [Woman 2] It's a big ask,
just because
I don't really talk
to Jason or Dylan.
- I think you should,
and I think you should say
that I told you to do it.
- [Woman 2] Okay.
- Use me as your air cover.
- And talk to Claude too.
When I have those
company meetings
or send those emails, I mean it.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- I know nobody believes me.
- [Woman 2] Well we don't
want to bother you.
- But I mean it.
- [Woman 2] Okay. Thank you.
- What's supposed
to happen otherwise?
- [Woman 2] Nothing.
- Right.
- [Woman 2] Not if you
don't act on it.
- And you have to act on
it with grace and respect.
You can't walk into
Jason and be like,
"You put me on
this now or fuck you."
That's not gonna work.
- [Woman 2] No.
- But even knowing that
that's what you're thinking
creates opportunity.
You didn't have to
say it to me now,
and if you didn't,
nothing would happen.
Now, you're gonna
say it to Claude,
you're gonna say it to Jason,
you're gonna say that
I told you to do that,
which then creates you all
the air cover (woman 2 laughs)
and then maybe
something will happen.
- [Woman 2] I hope so!
- [Gary] I hope so too.
But if nothing else,
now you know.
Just keeping it inside,
then you don't even know.
- [Woman 2] Right. Because
you never even vocalize it
to hear yourself say it
and be like, yeah,
you know, I actually
do want that.
- [Gary] Yeah. Again,
as long as you do it
with grace and respect, there's
nothing wrong with asking.
Demanding is very
different than asking.
- [Woman 2] Absolutely.
- [Man] Thanks Ty.
- [Gary] Thanks man.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Man 2] Something
important to me
that I want to share with you,
As you know it's been
a tough summer for me,
July was pretty
much a career low point,
it stopped me in my tracks,
I did a big reflect on myself,
my management approach.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Man 2] My
leadership approach,
management skills,
and I spent weeks identifying
areas of weakness,
places I can improve,
what I can do to make sure I'm--
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Man 2] bringing
your vision and
and Clyde give me some coaching,
I've modeled how he
was interacting with folks.
I looked back at my 18 months,
and identified the fact
that like I was really a
manager first and
not a leader and coach,
I was just trying to
keep it together.
- I get it,
and listen you know,
I'm a big boxing fan.
Styles make fights.
Two of the best boxers in
the world get in the ring,
you're sleeping by the
fifth round 'cause they both
have a similar defensive style
and it's not an
interesting fight.
- [Man 2] Right.
- You know there are leaders
in this company who've walked
into fluff situations
where all the
air cover's been created by me,
everything's fuckin' rosy.
- [Man 2] Right.
You walked in you know,
your timing in those 18 months,
you guys had a lot
of things to deal with,
so look I think you know
I didn't stop you the other day
and give you the
like I watch a lot,--
- [Man 2] Mhmmm.
- but I think you know I'm so
excited by the tone of your
conversation that I want to
equally throw back at you
as like sure,
we can all do things better,
you had an interesting
circumstance,
you know there's
a lot to do there.
You also have a partner
who's creative so you took on
the stress of everything.
I saw that.
- [Man 2] Our dynamic,
it like worked in 2015,
didn't work at the start.
- Yeah and also like,
it could work forever but the
things that it does to the
personality of the
person that has to
do that part runs the gamut.
Not to mention,
I forget nothing.
I remember soccer practice talk.
So like you know I'm empathetic.
There's a reason
you didn't get fired.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Keep going.
- [Man 2] So and
I want you to know
I listen to feedback,
I take it seriously.
(Gary blows raspberry)
- [Gary] I know better than that
because you've acted on it.
You can't act on something
you didn't hear so,
- [Man 2] Yeah, it's top
of mind for me every day.
- [Gary] It's going
really well, right?
- [Man 2] And I told Claude,--
- [Gary] Are you like pumped?
- I'm pumped.
- [Gary] Doesn't it
feel good too?
- I'm turning the corner.
- [Gary] Well I'm super aware.
- I mean when I look back at
my own management training,
I don't really have any.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man 2] I was a
freelance production guy,
I was a show running,
I had teams for a finite amount
of time and went away.
- [Gary] Listen, I know
so much of this.
Talk to me about the
part I'm interested in.
- [Man 2] So before,--
- Before that.
How does it feel to like
look at the peeps and the way
they look at you?
- [Man 2] Now?
- Yeah.
- [Man 2] It feels good,
also because I'm more focused.
- Yeah.
- [Man 2] Right,
I'm caring about,--
- Everything, you're caring
about everything now.
- [Man 2] Like I want to
know who these people are,
what they care about,--
- You care about everything now.
- [Man 2] And I have
enough people scaling me now
that I don't have to
do it for everybody.
- Yep.
- [Man 2] Like I got
two line producers.
- You know what else happens,
you know what else
happened to you?
It happens to
everybody at scale.
You start learning that
people are capable of
doing things too and if not,
you're even better
off letting them fail.
- [Man 2] Mhmmm.
- That's a big thing.
I mean you know this
I don't micromanage shit.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Biggest complaint of all you
senior is like am I even here,
like you know what I mean?
That's a huge value prop,
and that happens
at a scale growth too,
you can't do
everything sometimes.
That's good, man.
- [Man 2] So yeah I wanted
you to know that I intend on
earning back the trust.
- By the way,
that little winky wink
I gave you was
massive acknowledgement of that.
By the way I generally
believe my trust was waning,
but I don't know
we fire a lot of
people when trust,
like to me trust is interesting.
Like it's very binary
either I have it or I don't.
So truth is I kind
of always had it.
I wasn't pumped as much as
I am right now about it,
right now I'm very confident.
Especially because
you have big advantage
over a lot of other people.
You've tasted
both sides of it now.
- [Man 2] Sure.
- Like I have more
confidence in you now
than 90 percent of the org.
- [Man 2] No, mean I was
feeling on thin ice all summer.
- Yeah I'm sure you were.
- [Man 2] And I know
I was a burden.
- You weren't a burden.
- [Man 2] I didn't want,--
- Listen here's the good news,
here's the good news.
I appreciate that but you
know what we all went to bat.
We were all fighting for it,
we were fighting for it.
Think about how cool that is.
We were fighting for it to work.
- [Man 2] Right.
- That's what nobody gets,
like, that gets me so mad.
Only thing I do is to
fight to make it work.
- [Man 2] Okay.
- The amount of money, time
and energy that this company
deploys to have
this conversation
is through the roof.
And the sad part is I only
get to have one of these
for every four you know?
- [Man 2] Right.
- All the others is wasted time
and money and energy, right?
But this is so valuable.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
I appreciate it I've been
looking forward to this moment,
I had one with Claude
I had one with James,
I want to get to know that
I'm very focused.
- [Gary] The whole thing
is going very well.
- [Man 2] It's top of mind,
my interactions.
- [Gary] Your people know it.
Dude, the fucking
way they feel
about you is
fundamentally different.
- [Man 2] Good,
I'm glad that's coming through.
- It's real.
- [Man 2] Yeah,
I mean my 2015
was very like results-driven.
- I get it.
- [Man 2] Build this practice,
this year it's about like,--
- And you were drinking
out of a fire hose,
there's a million variables.
- [Man 2] How do I care
about the people that are here?
- I fucking I really genuinely
thought the Aaron thing
was gonna work out.
I thought he would
bringing you value.
- [Man 2] Yeah, and we
were close before.
- I know which is
why I was confident.
- [Man 2] He was
even my boss,
but now it's a different,--
- It's a different thing
because I also know,
you also have to
understand he was also
molded in a different way here.
You know, it wasn't
that he's better or,
he just had the
benefit of kind of,
think about what you're
gonna do for everybody now.
He just had the benefit of
going through it you know?
Maybe he didn't have
the same narrative.
That's almost really irrelevant.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
So now we have some new hires,--
- Yep.
- [Man 2] And more
creative producers--
- Yep.
- [Man 2] I'm spending
most of my time with them
because structurally we're
a little stronger across.
- Yep, yep, yep.
- [Man 2] And I want them
to have a good experience
every day a positive.
And when I give critical
feedback I want you to know,
that I'm also like
scrunching it on both sides.
- Honey empire.
- [Man 2] Right reinforcement.
- [Man 2] You're
doing a great job,
show me your work.
- Honey empire.
- [Man 2] And
I'm seeing the results.
- Of course.
- [Man 2] Last year it
was like surgical strikes,
in that it wasn't
working for them.
- [Gary] It doesn't work,
it's not how humans work.
You'd be a great engineer,
you understand?
- Yeah, maybe.
Thank you.
- I'm super pumped.
This was super fun.
- [Man 2] Last thing.
So you guys see and keep
hearing good things about me.
- I believe that.
- [Man 2] I'm heads
down I'm making this
coming back from it,
I'd love it if you could
spend some time with us.
- [Gary] It's a very
big conversation here.
- Okay cool.
- [Gary] Very big.
- Maybe we could do
like a town hall thing.
- [Gary] It's a very big deal.
- People can do Q&amp;A.
- [Gary] 'Cause it's a problem
and now I'm going away for
this TV show,
it's a top two
stress in my life.
But I also had to like
work on the meeting
we're about to have like,
I've gotta I've got some ideas
of also what I want that to
be and how I want it to be,
which you'll be working with
me on via Skype probably
November, December
all good stuff.
The answer's yes.
- [Man 2] Okay, cool.
- The answer's yes.
- Like I said maybe at
the end of this month
if you have an opening.
- [Gary] I'm gonna
try to sneak one in
before the end of the year
and then I'm going to
be there every month.
- 'Cause I think people
want to get connected.
- [Gary] They have to,
no, no it's a real thing,
it's a real thing.
Alright, brother.
Talk to you soon.
Thank you so much.
- [Man 2] Have a good one.
- [Gary] That was a lot of fun.
- [Woman 3] Oh wow.
Okay, been here six months.
I came in from the world
of music entertainment,
my previous job was with
Mr. Combs at Cave Diddy.
- I'm aware.
Alex loved meeting
with you and all that,
he kept like back sharing
he's like you've got Jodi,
you're gonna love this.
- [Woman 3] When I first
came here I was like a little
nervous only because
I came from chaos.
- Yes.
- Working in that
type of industry,
so just seeing how everything
is like tight knit here
kind of scared me but
I started falling to place.
I was able to be myself 'cause
I'm not the one to be like,
not prim or proper or
coming from like Ivy League
schools like these kids but,
I came in from a strong
background of just dealing
with hands on,
- [Gary] Like doing.
Learning from doing.
- That's how I learn
from doing it.
- Me too and I think the
thing that think you've
probably already learned
is if you're good enough,
I don't care if you've
been here for 40 years,
I don't care if
you're my cousin,
I don't care if you are a
Patriots fan which I would hate,
(woman 3 laughs)
like if you can do it both
in your skill and in how
you roll as a person,
just like I made the video
I don't know if you watched it,
honey empire.
- [Woman 3] Yeah.
- I care about both.
- [Woman 3] Yeah 'cause
I was scared coming in as like
oh is she a little bit too
like I didn't even want to
use the term but like too
urban or is she gonna fall
straight with clients or is
she gonna I mean you saw,--
- I'm the most rogue
of the whole bunch.
- [Woman 3] Right but
when I see a lot of,
I forget to keep comparing
but I see a lot off how Puff
groomed me to like working here.
- This is you know like look
I don't know how you know
Puff's world looks
but to me like,
definitely not too urban.
To me it doesn't
matter what the culture,
what makes this place great
is no matter what it is,
the skills both in people skills
and hard work will trump
anything.
- [Woman 3] Yeah, yeah
definitely
I love here and
I love working here.
- [Gary] Good, good.
- I'm have a great time here,
I'm happy I'm here.
- [Gary] Keep it going,
ping me you ever need me.
- Yes, thank you.
- [Gary] Take care.
You're welcome.
- [Sophia] Hi.
- [Gary] Hi, how are you?
- I'm Gary.
- Sophia.
- Sophia, how are you?
- So good to finally meet.
- Such a pleasure.
How long have you been here?
- So I've been here for
like a month and a half.
I started interning,
they offered me
the Junior Art Director
position two weeks in.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And it's been amazing.
I'm working with Aytana.
- [Gary] Yep.
- It's been incredible.
- [Gary] Good.
- And crazy Vayner pride.
That makes me happy.
- Yeah, I've just been
taking on projects
and getting involved
with different people
and trying to carry out
what Vayner stands
for, and, yeah.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- So I actually brought this
because, so I asked
everyone in the office
to doodle a picture of
something that like
resonates with them
and that they love.
I scanned all of them and
I'm going to collaborate
all of the doodles and make
like a big piece of art
for the office.
- [Gary] I love it!
- New awesome office.
So I brought this
for you to maybe
when you get a second--
- Doodle?
- To doodle for me.
- [Gary] Yes.
I'll doodle while we talk.
- [Sophia] Okay.
- I've got my, I've got
doodling capabilities.
So tell me about yourself.
Where are you from?
- [Sophia] I'm from the city.
- New York?
- Yeah, New York City.
- Awesome.
- On the Upper West Side,
and then I also
grew up in Israel.
- Is that right?
- [Sophia] Yeah.
- Where, Tel Aviv, or
- [Sophia] Jerusalem.
- Jerusalem, how long
did you live there?
- [Sophia] For about
five years total.
- And what, what times?
- [Sophia] From fourth
grade to eighth grade.
- Yep.
- [Sophia] And then every summer
I worked on a Kibbutz
for two months.
- That's cool.
- [Sophia] And then...
- So I was born in Belarus.
- [Sophia] Yeah, nice.
- And I left
in '78,
when all the Jews left,
and so a lot of my family
went to Israel too.
- [Sophia] Nice.
- And, but everybody
eventually made it to
the U.S. by the mid-80s.
- [Sophia] Cool.
- But I get it.
- [Sophia] Nice.
- It's cool.
- [Sophia] And are you Jewish?
- Mhmmm.
- [Sophia] Oh, okay.
- So in '78,
there was something
where I left Russia
through political asylum
because Israel and the U.S.
teamed up to get Jews
out of Soviet Russia.
- [Sophia] Yeah.
- Because it wasn't
a very good scene for Jews
in Soviet Russia.
- I know.
- So, that's kind
of my background.
- [Sophia] I love it!
(Gary laughs)
Awesome!
- [Gary] And so what
else are you into,
like are you super art,
oh my God, I almost wear,
I cannot believe
you're wearing those sneakers.
- [Sophia] Aren't they
fucking amazing?
- [Gary] Not only are
they fucking amazing,
I actually started
putting them on
and decided I wanted to go
low top instead of high top
cause I was lazy.
- [Sophia] Oh!
I want to get a low one.
- We literally, literally
almost wore the
same sneakers today.
- [Sophia] So, you had
the low top of the Flyknit?
- No, I have that exact pair.
- Oh!
- But I was lazy this morning.
I pulled them out, and it
takes me an extra second
to put those on versus low tops.
- [Sophia] Agreed.
- And I was like, fuck that,
I don't have a second.
- [Sophia] I feel you.
- [Priscilla] Hello!
- Hello!
- [Priscilla] It's nice
to finally meet you.
- It's nice to meet you,
Priscilla.
- [Priscilla] Fourth time,
maybe.
How are you doing?
- How are you?
Good to see you.
- Great!
I'm a little cold, I'm
shaking because of that,
not because of you.
- [Gary] No worries.
- Always have that
blanket on, so I have
to thank you for that.
- [Gary] No worries.
- Like, I can't bring
it into his office.
- [Gary] So tell me about
yourself, Priscilla.
- So I am from Florida.
I moved to
New York City back in April
with no job or place to live.
I just knew I had to be here.
I was an advertising major,
there's a lot of opportunity
in Sarasota, honestly,
it's an old people town.
- [Gary] I know it well.
- And so, really?
- [Gary] Yeah!
- Small world.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So I said, alright,
you know what, if
advertising's what I want to do,
I need to go get my feet wet
where the art of industry is,
that was New York City.
So I packed up my suitcases,
I couch hopped
from friend to friend for
about three and a half weeks.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Yeah, I found a place,
a sub-lease in Astoria, Queens,
'cause it was pretty cheap.
And then I eventually
got this job,
but I have to tell you, the
weirdest thing about it all
was that, I didn't even
know what VaynerMedia was,
and I didn't know who you were.
This was before
I got my interview.
But I saw a video
of you preaching
to recent college grads.
(Gary laughs)
I graduated in 2015,
and it was just saying,
no, you have this five year
window to attack it,
blah blah blah.
And I was like, wow,
this guy's amazing,
it's so inspirational, so
I posted it on Facebook.
A week later, Alex reaches
out, I have my interview,
I meet Joe and Camillo, and
I eventually get the job.
And I looked at my Facebook
timeline, and I noticed
that it said Gary Vaynerchuk,
I was like, no fucking way,
that's my CEO!
(Gary laughs)
I'm working for his company now!
- [Gary] That's so awesome.
- So it's crazy.
- [Gary] That's so cool.
- Yeah, but I am happy here.
- [Gary] I'm glad.
- I am happy here,
I didn't move to New York
to settle for any job.
I, you know, moved here
to chase my dreams
and to work hard and to
hopefully, you know, succeed.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- And I love Vayner.
- What can I answer for you,
anything you're curious about?
- All the changes that have
been happening, I guess,
in terms of--
- There's a lot more coming.
- Yeah, I'm sure.
You know, is there any
insights you can give already
as to how it's been going?
Like, I know you said--
- I mean, it's all going
to always be good.
- Yeah?
- [Gary] Like, I don't know,
like the video I said,
like if you have true
heart and good intent
and good stuff,
- [Frank] Mhmmm.
- And you're also a fucking
beast and wants to rip
people's throats out of their
bodies, you'll always win.
- [Frank] Okay.
- So, you know,
how's it going?
It's all pockets, you know,--
- [Frank] Right.
- we're at scale.
- [Frank] That's good.
- Some things are going
phenomenal,
some things are horse shit,
but net-net, unbelievable and
about to get way better.
- [Frank] So, cool.
- Communicate, is the biggest
thing I would tell you.
- [Frank] Ah.
- Don't get just
pocketed into your world.
And those mentors,
use Claude, use me.
I think of it as, everybody
out there is governors,
and this is like D.C.
- [Frank] Okay. Yeah.
- Keep that in mind,
if you ever need it.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I mean, the vibes
I'm getting, it seems
like it's going
really well, so I'm not,
but you never know, right?
- [Frank] Mhmmm.
- You get put on team,
manager above you is, you know,
the thing I'm worried about for
a guy that fits your profile
is there's always that
concern around meritocracy.
If there's like raw talent,
how they handle
the patience game when
people above them around them
aren't playing that same game.
That's a tricky one.
- [Frank] Mhmmm.
- But if you can win it,
you win big.
- [Frank] Yeah.
- I spent my whole life
interacting with people
that are not as strong as I am.
I mean that.
- [Frank] Yeah.
- Once you cannot calibrate
that, it all fucking flows.
- [Frank] Okay.
- Lot easier when you fucking
eat the shit for 20 years
like I did to get to the point.
Not as fun early in the game.
- [Frank] Mhmmm.
- But I'm telling you
that in case you ever want
to have a conversation about it.
- [Frank] Okay,
thank you very much.
- [Gary] Have a great day, man.
- [Frank] Pleasure to meet you.
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Tyler] If you spend 15 here,
you're gonna be 15 behind.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Hello!
- Hi!
- Hi.
How are you?
You were so fired up,
I was intrigued.
(team laughing)
So hey, just want to spend
some time with you guys
and say hello and see what's up.
Kim and I were chatting,
we thought it'd be a good idea
to get together, like we
have in some other times.
I guess, in the limited
time that we have,
as I was thinking
about this meeting,
I think the first and
foremost thing is--
there's a tricky thing
I want to start with
and I want to hedge it by
saying that it's a tricky thing.
Because I think you guys
remember with the all hands-on.
I've a lot of fear of
the entertainment team,
the creative team,
the Bud Lite team.
I have enormous fear of that.
However, that's just life.
I mean, there's only so
far communism can take you.
(team laughing)
With that said, and with
it being very important,
and I would say, I want
to be very transparent.
There's a lot of people here
that I hope I get to interact
with for the rest of my career.
And yours.
That it's important to
not let it trump anything
that is the logo, but
with that being said,
the first thing
I want to start with is
thanking you from
the bottom of my heart
of having enormously strong DNA
in the thing that
I probably care about the most
when push comes to
shove, which is this team
over the last forever and
definitely over this last year
has performed at a hustle
level that is inspiring to me
and, very honestly,
brings me vibes that I want to
break all of you up and put
you in all different places
so that you can
bring that to the table.
And so, for that,
I want to thank you.
And really, it's appreciated.
It's very real.
Two, I though about something
that was super important
to me.
There's so many people in this
room that I just don't spend
any time with.
It's funny, I was saying
something to the others
that have been here,
Alex,
I'm just never gonna
win this game.
Just not gonna win this game.
You know, I'm just not.
I have to fucking--
It's kind of like the Jets.
I just have to wrap
my head around it
(team laughing)
It's not happening.
But, anything I can do in
this limited time together
right now.
I'm a very fond
believer in the leaders
of this ecosystem.
But, what if you're having
a problem with them?
It's not super fun to--
Like, how do you have that talk?
If you're struggling with
your boss, or your boss's boss
or your boss's boss.
One analogy that I'm gonna
start using a lot of in here,
is the United States.
And I kind of view some
of the things you'll see
structurally that
I'm about to announce
and kind of what's in
place with me and Claude,
that I refer to, or James is,
you know, I look at
Chris and Kim
and I look at them as governors.
And I look at myself
as Washington D.C.
I really genuinely want
you guys to know this.
And I don't know if you know it.
I think some of you know it,
but I'm gonna just pound it.
I just don't have anymore
vested interest in
who's saying Chris
or Kim versus Jody.
I just don't.
To me, it's all the same.
The quicker people
understand that,
the quicker they feel safe.
The quicker we can
have real conversations,
the quicker I can address shit.
Obviously the video I sent last
week in lieu with the email,
I'm not gonna be able
to defeat what happens
outside these four walls that
creates an enormous amount of
cynicism, fear, negativity.
But I will chip away at it.
And if I can get one of you
to feel more comfortable
to stop by and say hello,
I mean, Katie,
I don't fucking like--
I don't wanna go
(team laughing)
Katie, I don't wanna go
four years in between
five minute chats.
(team laughing)
You know what I mean?
Now listen, very frankly,
to some of you,
if shit's cruising and
it's phenomenal, great.
'Cause I'll take the
five minutes back.
'Cause there's
74,000 other fires,
but I want to continue
to pound to remind you,
especially when
you get it caught into
such a tight knit ecosystem,
that this is not VaynerMedia.
VaynerMedia is
different for every person
based on the
people they interact with.
But the intent
is very consistent.
And I just have to
continue to pound that.
Finally, really,
I just kind of thought
what would be really smart
for five to 10 minutes
is maybe do a Q&amp;A.
You know, I've been talking a
big game of town hall Q&amp;A
for the whole company.
I've been miserably inefficient
since I haven't delivered on it.
It's already top of mind for
like, I have to crack that nut.
Because I think it
will solve a lot.
And so, I'll banter for
another two minutes here
while I get you to think
about how much courage,
or what question
you want to ask.
But, as I stall for that one
minute, I'm very very thankful
for you guys' efforts.
I'm excited.
There's a lot good stuff
coming down the pipe.
A lot of exciting stuff.
Our brand within the
ecosystem of entertainment
is very strong and growing.
I'm getting a lot of
inquiries from studio owners
and media companies
and networks.
And so, I'm really, really
proud of what's going on here
and I want to
thank you guys for that.
I think it'd be really smart
for you to clap for each other
and then look directly
in somebody's--
(team applause)
Look in somebody's face!
I apologize for the
cheesy nature of that,
but boy do I fucking love--
(team laughing)
I love fucking clapping!
("You're Welcome" by Jura Kez)
In SVP, there's a lot!
This is big!
This has been a lot
of time in the making.
This is a lot of my off,
you know, August by myself.
How do I win in '17.
(laughing)
You're like, motherfucker,
I haven't been able to watch
one play of an Indians game.
In 10 minutes, I have
to go speak at Columbia.
But I'll see you
Friday probably.
- Okay.
- I mean, super punch line is
I made a macro decision
predicated on my beliefs that
you wanted to go into
the CPG world with me.
Let's go.
Avi's outside?
- [Tyler] Yep.
- [Gary] Avi!
- [Tyler] Does Avi know exactly
the hall you're going into?
Classroom's 301.
- [Gary] 301?
That's my dorm room!
- Let's do it.
- This is what you have for her?
- This is what I planned.
I have a second email
with other stuff.
If you don't want
to go with this,
but I think that this will be--
- So Foxglove is going?
- The signee is the next one.
Peter's gonna
have it any minute.
- Great.
- Cornerstone--
- So are we going to
price it right now, or?
- Sure.
- We can do that.
- Yeah, you ready?
- Yep.
- And how did you want
me to market to Foxglove,
If there's any other way?
Did you want me to title it,
do you want to title
something like that?
- I definitely want to title it.
- Okay.
- Make sure I do, okay?
- I can probably
do that tomorrow.
I'll go on WiFi and catch up.
- That's fine.
- That's when?
This Thursday?
- Next Thursday.
Yeah the Wide's
coming in tomorrow.
- Okay.
- Signee is $10 cost,
searcher's 19.99, one store,
MSRP is $24, it's 91 Parker.
It's 350 cases, remember?
We didn't really have anything.
- Let's go 24.99, 19.99.
And let's go 18.99,
free shipping by the case.
For one day only.
Got it?
Where's the Cornerstone Pinot?
You'll get me that bottle?
We need that.
- You'll rate that
probably, right?
- Mhmmm.
I'll probably
make a video too.
When am I here, DRock,
Thursday night?
Friday?
- [DRock] Thursday.
- [Gary] I'm here in the
office Friday, right?
- [DRock] Yes.
- [Gary] We have
to do it Friday.
We should always be--
- One buck less?
- Or some price less
and free shipping.
Got it?
We had that for a little bit.
- Okay.
("Working Together" by Jura Kez)
- [Gary] See ya, let's go.
You know where we're going?
Do you know how dead
I would have been doing
that two years ago?
Hey, man.
Oh.
(students laugh)
I'm so sorry.
There was something
interesting just happened.
Did you ask him would
he invest in the person
who if he took the term deal,
which was the early deal,
right?
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- Well the answer to,
the interesting part there
that was interesting was
he would have not known
the other outcome.
Like, if they took that first
deal, he just wouldn't know.
- [Man 4] Right.
- So I think, I think
that's something I'm always
fascinated by, which is
people are so crippled
by decisions.
There's just no way to know
what would have happened
you know, at the time, when
you're making that decision.
So much of this is Monday
morning quarterbacking,
that I'm fascinated.
Anyway, nonetheless.
- Let's move over
into the middle.
- Yeah.
(students laugh)
I've known this man since
I was 14, 15 years old
because my family had a
liquor store in Springfield,
New Jersey, that I started
working at when I was 14,
that I later turned into
something called Wine Library.
And launched one of
the first three or four
e-commerce wine
businesses in America
called WineLibrary.com.
Back in 1996,
and your professor
here was a hardcore
wine nerd that knew
way too much about wine
for such a young dude.
And I was a child,
but that was my whole life
and what I cared about.
I built my dad's business
from a three to a $65 million
business, but I did it on
digital marketing
innovation of the time.
In 1997, I had an email
newsletter that had 91 percent
open rates because nobody
was e-mail marketing.
And instead of sending
catalogs from Sherry Lehman's
or Zackie's, I was
getting to customers first
with the hottest wines
on this thing "e-mail"
and I was trying to send
as many e-mails as possible
in 1997 because
I thought people would
eventually charge for it.
Like it was just like, it
seemed such a great deal.
(students laugh)
Launching a website, e-mail,
really, it's funny, but very
honestly, if we start talking
about VR, we're going to start
making a lot of assumptions
right now that are either
play out or not play out
in a 20, 30 year window.
1996 internet was a whole
different fucking world.
And so, I kept innovating,
bought the word wine on
the day Google AdWords came
out, for five cents a click.
That was a good bet.
And owned it for a long time,
and just did a lot of smart
digital marketing things.
And then I did a show on
YouTube a couple months after
YouTube came out
called Wine Library TV,
where I sat in front of
a camera and drank four
bottles of wine
for twenty minutes.
(students laugh)
And a lot of people watched
that, and that's how I kind of
hit the scene in the tech world.
And then what happened was
YouTube sold for $1.7 billion
and I was like,
fuck, I was right about
e-com, I was right
about Google AdWords,
I was right about you know,
cookie re-targeting banner ads.
I was right about YouTube,
maybe this skill I have
for selling more burgundy
and priorat can be deployed
against something more
financially interesting.
So when I read the article
about YouTube's sale,
there was one article
that featured Ron Conway's
Angel Investor investment,
and I said,
"What the fuck's
an Angel Investor?"
I googled it.
(students laugh)
And you know, within twenty
minutes decided I would be
an Angel Investor.
And went to South By
Southwest three months later,
became friends with
Ev Williams and Blane Cook,
the original CTO, and
I think your firm at the time,
me and Kevin Rose bought
up Blane's original stock
at Twitter, so I bought a
ton of twitter real cheap.
- [Professor] Yeah.
- I didn't think of myself
as an angel investor,
I just thought that
was a smart decision,
'cause I thought
Twitter would be big.
Then I went home from South-By.
- [Professor] Did it
do good, by the way?
- Well it did for me
because I sold my shares.
So I did good.
(students laugh)
Came home, made a video.
I was making wine videos,
came home,
made a video that said
Facebook should be
worried about Twitter.
There was a guy head of
platform at the time at Facebook
that I didn't know by
the name of Dave Morin.
Sent me an e-mail,
he's like, hey,
this video has gone really
viral inside of Facebook.
Would you come out to
Palo Alto and give a talk?
So I came to a room like
this, when, in front of the
whole company,
it was only 400 employees.
And talked about consumer
behavior and why I thought
the world was changing.
That caught Mark's attention,
we went out to dinner
that night, and a week later
I bought a lot of stock
from his parents.
And then somehow I got
David Karp to re-open
the B-round of Tumblr.
And, by the way,
stick with me here,
the B-round had a
$14 million valuation.
And I made an
investment into Tumblr,
so the first three
things I invested in were
Twitter, Facebook, and Tumblr.
(students laugh)
- That was wise.
- Yeah, I mean,
it was when I was smart.
I was making bets on things
that I thought would
be successful.
I didn't think of
myself as an investor.
I got progressively
stupider after that.
(students laugh)
But,
- [Professor] Why do
you think that was?
- Because I started
trying to be an investor.
I literally went from being,
I'm a businessman,
these are good businesses.
This is good.
The market changed.
And this is Tumblr B-round 2008,
B-round 14 million.
Now every fake bullshit
entrepreneur running around
this campus wants 7 million,
4 million for their
bullshit idea that they
have no prayer on because
entrepreneurship is popular,
and instead of going to
Bain and McKenzie they think
they can start a fucking app
that people are going to use.
(students laugh)
(students applaud)
- [Professor] So those
of you who are clapping,
are you clapping because
he just described you?
(all laugh)
- The brand equity around
being an entrepreneur today
is stunning, it is
stunning for me to,
in the world, like I can't
believe how cool it is
in real life to be an
entrepreneur, and that makes a
lot of young individuals
gravitate towards that.
- Is that, but you, you're
suggesting overall that's worse
than if those young
individuals went to work for
Goldman Sachs or McKenzie.
- I am. 'Cause I'll tell
you what we are not,
- Do you see the world as
a better place, even with
the bad ideas are getting,--
- No, I do not.
And let me explain why.
The biggest conversation
that I'm fascinated by
is the suicide rate
at Warton last year.
So we have, in parallel,
a narrative that anybody
can do it and
everybody's entitled
to win at entrepreneurship.
And there's an underbelly
in our world that
I'm concerned about,
and you know
we've talked about this
in different panel,
this is a big thing.
Like, when you are,
there are certain individuals
who have been winning
in the first twenty years
of their life in a game
that was fixed
before they played it.
And then they
go into the market.
And the market
punches them in the mouth,
and they don't
know how to react.
And so yes, I do think, for
the clichÊ paint a picture
that I'm painting right now,
there are certain individuals
that I just genuinely
believe would have
had a better life being
the number seven at Facebook,
instead of the
number one of Shitbook.
(students laugh)
Or, or, or,
making 230,000 a year,
on Wall Street or Consulting
Land at 29 years old.
Yes, I think there's a lot of
people that will be better.
Like, I love entrepreneurship
the most, but nothing
works when it's
forced or off-balance.
Nothing.
You know, I don't get
to judge who should.
I'm just excited to see
how it all plays out.
(students laugh)
Do you know what I mean?
I mean, who should?
Who should do
anything in the world?
The people, you know,
what I love about this is
they'll be plenty of
winners during this era.
There'll just be
a lot more losers.
You know?
And so, that's all,
just a timing thing,
'cause it's so classic.
This is every market on
everything, always and forever,
it's why I love brand so much.
This is when brand
takes over reality.
(bag drops)
(all laugh)
Yeah. I know, that
was a big statement.
(students laugh)
So, I think a lot of,
I grew out of,
my crew grew out of the Angel,
Super Angel, guys and
gals that were successful
in their first
internet business,
made some money
and were getting,
had enough Twitter followers,
let's get to the punch line,
to attract
unbelievable deal flow.
I made a lot of money, I made
a lot, I'm going to continue
to make a lot of
money from that pocket.
But a lot of us shouldn't
necessarily be investors.
We may be, should be keeping
some investment behavior,
but we should all
really map ourselves,
but I think yeah it's all
really, I think all of this
comes down to the supply
and demand of the skills,
and I just think people are
very attracted to this world.
And I think, especially when
I sit in a class like this,
you know, I try to reverse
engineer every situation
I'm in, especially,
how do I bring value?
If I can get one
person in this room,
to actually pay attention
tonight, go home,
look in the mirror, and
try to start deploying
aggressive self-awareness,
it could change
the upside of their lives.
I genuinely believe that.
I just,--
- As long as they don't
work for Goldman Sachs.
- Or they should,
I mean, I really,
or maybe they should work
for their family business,
I don't know.
But I know that way too many
people just go with the flow.
I know how strong-minded
I am, and how easy that is for
me to get caught up and so
I just think it's a worthwhile
conversation, especially
'cause too many people
make a decision on the
now, not on when they're
actually playing it out.
Doesn't really matter to you
if you're going to this world
today, it matters what the
impact is over a 36 to 60 month
window you have
to really quantify that.
Looking at data told
you what happened.
You need to deploy real
intuition and other kind of
signs to what's going to
happen, so you can make
the decision for you.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- Good to see you, buddy.
- Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Thanks for having me.
I'm sorry I'm late.
- No.
This is great.
I appreciate it.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- Tie?
- Yes. Yes.
- [Man 4] I wanna do a picture.
I'm gonna get in the middle.
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- Oh, by the way,
I wanna continue.
- I love when we talk.
- This is the second
time we've talked.
- It's fun.
Yeah.
- I really wanna continue.
- Pitch in.
(Gary laughs)
- It's good to see you, brother.
Great to see you.
Talk to you soon.
Hey, wanted to meet this guy.
How are you, man?
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Thanks for coming today.
- No problem.
I mean, I got out of
school today first of all.
- That's the best part.
- Gonna use that.
Gonna use any excuse possible.
- [Gary] Love it.
- Absolutely despise school.
So anything I can
do to get out of that.
Awesome to finally meet you.
- Thank you, man.
- I think Eliot
may have explained.
- Yup, yup.
- You actually, whether
you know it or not,
connected the two of us.
270 something #AskGaryVee.
- Yup.
- Eliot picked my question.
You said connect with him.
- Yup.
- I honestly didn't
even know that there was
someone that age
doing what I was doing.
I did the Facebook version
of what Eliot does.
- Yup.
- I had no idea that
there was someone else
because obviously.
- Sure, I know how it works.
- You're behind the logo.
- Yup, yup.
- You have no idea.
- Yeah, of course.
- So to see Eliot and you.
Connect with Eliot.
Tons of phone calls.
- Nice.
- I'm helping him currently
build his Facebook.
- [Gary] Love it.
- He's helping me
build my Instagram.
- [Gary] I love it.
Keep jamming.
- But yeah, so I just
wanted to come here.
First of all let you
know that your content is
something that I look
at when I'm looking for
content for myself.
- [Gary] Yup.
- Three things.
Information.
- [Gary] Yup.
- Motivation.
- And entertainment.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Very, very few
people provide all three.
- [Gary] I appreciate it, man.
I appreciate it.
That's a very big compliment.
Ready to go?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Cool.
Bye, guys.
Thank you.
- Thank you, that was awesome.
- Thanks for having us.
Thank you.
("Free Form" by Skilly Music)
Headed back home.
Gonna change into a suit.
Go to a charity event.
Some friends and fam.
And then maybe head our
for a couple more meetings.
Good day.
Fun meetings.
The grind is on.